this is absolutely hilarious.
Remember that obvious scam that was a go fund
me campaign claiming to be raising money to
build Donald Trump's wall on the US Mexico
border and $20 million.
We're actually donated.
This is the wall by the way.
That was definitely going to be paid for by
Mexico, is that we've not heard a word about
from Donald Trump for about three months now.
Back in December, a guy named Brian Kolfage
started a go fund me campaign saying, the
government won't do it if Trump won't do it.
If Democrats will get in the way, we can do
it ourselves.
Let's raise the money.
We're going to try to raise $1 billion.
Which of course, even if they did would have
only paid for like a tiny sliver of wall.
Kolfage said that every penny would be refunded
if they didn't get the billion dollars.
Well, they didn't get the billion dollars.
They raised $20 million of people's money,
which is insane.
And he claims he's not giving the money back
because he is going to start building parts
of the wall on private land and that's why
he's not refunding people's money.
And supposedly they were going to break ground
in April.
We're now in May.
Nothing has actually been done.
The updates to the go fund me page have slowed
down to being almost nonexistent.
And now like only now these absolutely imbecilic
Trump supporters and wall builders are starting
to sit to think, starting to suggest that
maybe they were scammed and they throw their
money away at something.
Absolutely.
And totally ridiculous.
And of course there are some donors who are
starting to say, authorities should really
step in and take care of this.
They should help us get our money back from
the scam, which doesn't really sound like
small government to me.
And I'm not one of these ultra libertarian
buyer beware types.
I do believe in government regulation.
I do believe in government oversight and all
of that.
You know, that if you've been watching this
show for awhile, but go fund me has disclaimers
about how the donor must research what they're
donating to.
Why exactly should the government step in
here and refund people's money.
But there's an even bigger truth here, which
is undeniable, which is that if you voted
for Donald Trump, you got scammed, right?
I mean, the entire campaign was a scam by
a professional scammer, Trump university,
Trump steaks, Trump's real estate deals, Trump's
campaign, and Trump's presidency.
It's all been a scam.
If you got bamboozled into voting for Trump,
it's not really that surprising that you fell
for this obvious and stupid go fund me scam
to build the wall.
The universe of Trump is riddled with, it's
almost exclusively bogus, empty promises.
So Trump is, we're really the perfect mark
for Brian Kolfage to raise $20 million off
of them, supposedly to build a wall.
Uh, I will make an offer today to every single
person who donated to this wall and thinks
it might be a scam.
Send me 100 bucks and I'll investigate for
you whether you got scammed and I'll get you
a report about that very, very soon.
Give me a break guys.
Okay.
If you couldn't tell that this was an obvious
scam from the beginning, I don't think that
you, uh, deserve any of the money back and
certainly it should not be the government
bailing you out.
Although I would be totally fine with a, a
civil suit against Brian Kolfage if that's
the way you want to approach it, let me know
what you think.
Should the government step in here?
I think the answer is no.